7 seconds left in this PK slamed with it and
he scores shorthanded the puck elevation and
it pays off for him in game one to go pink
short side poke over to Han to the point not
out Mory kept it in here's shley scores and
they're going to get reward come Conor with
the for check and creating that turnover
getting it back to the point Brandon ha
with a good feed stamp Co in there's the
shot cars whoa that's why stamp Co scores
like he does Detroit actually got back on
the move his cousins create space shoots
SC Johansson's leaning to his left and it takes a
perfect shot off of the post you can see him push
it Out Of sher's Reach and absolutely snapped that
one off the Lawrence joins the battle Puck comes
up the boards to stenland he moves he fires
he scores Samson up he went down early look
at the rise of that Puck and off the post and in
he's knocked off balance and Here Come the Ducks
with numbers mnov across the line with stro takes
the shot rebound stro scores off the pad you can
see stro he's got to adjust to get the backand on
and he does it's just to chip Lin in front of the
power there's gos to spare they take the shot away
does Alexia down to LK what a shot top Corner whoa
Dyan lens got the team [Applause] leid here's bar
Boule he'll cut back look to the line for perix
perix serach here's Point Wade shoots scor braed
points Gos in backto back the Flyers break it out
now here comes another wild draft kick drops it
nicely connected quick shot [Applause] go you
look at the way the pliers they on their heels a
little since that last uh that last penalty kill
and Steeler doesn't well you don't want to you
don't want to look too deep into some of these
plays but Merill retreating right there here's
another chance and Rosy scores can hear the pipe
all the way up here pipe glove side and in here's
heric to Hughes all the blues over a minute and a
half as he [Applause] scores but Sammy bla here a
little late out for the defensive coverage allows
the pass over and then Quinn use overtime
against Vegas on Friday to start this road
trip Kevin kinsky now pass across Bard [Applause]
scores and he puts a dart over that glove yeah at
this point that's what it's all about is making
the stop on the next one so you don't get spread
out too much another shot score not this time
KV lights the lamp he can shoot it off a stand
still like very few players in the game look
there's nothing going on it's a deflected Puck
Here Comes Paige Thompson three on two for
Buffalo another eyan Rush dropping it back
off score excellent Rush net front Presence by
Greenway and then right off the post and in and
the minute Greenway drove that lane RM it all the
way back for Jared mccan mccan goes deeper in the
zone and back for Schultz this way bork strand
a shot he's SC Q the Maestro it's a power play
goal for Oliver [Music] borr with the tip try
beer scores his first NHL goal the Stars got
into a mess with their defensive Zone coverage
the Bruins were able to reather the puck in a
perfect seven game gold rout here's a 20 on for
Vancouver lafy in theiler lafy shoots picked out
home the [Applause] scores and he'll send it down
and kerfoot finally gets to the bench here's an
opportunity melli over the line what a shot to
goal Matias melli posted in we're tied at one
turns to the outside finds Ras M turning shooting
and scores Michael Ras M this time off the post
and in CL cson standing right there but enough of
a screen a wrist shot off the pipe and in the net
one for its last nine garos on the draw one back
to kner instead that's within his range good job
of Matthews getting it to the outside and the
quick little rer positioned a little dry CLE
outlets and carried up by by Darnell nurse nurse
two onone he shoots scores play around the world
as dry settle on the outlet pass to Darnell Mur
and that's a great position to shoot the puck
wheeler has hit Escape think it back by fanty and
he scores Adam F Tilly has answered back with the
Columbus Blue Jackets and tied it B off up the
left side here come the Hurricanes back into the
flyer Zone D'Angelo back across score na the
hurricanes are on the board exactly what you
need to do top shelf no chance for heart looks
like Crossing in for his first win is Suzuki on
the puck he gets drilled by elel Suzuki on his
skates able to free it reot score Alex new hook
with the rocket Nick Suzuki does a good job
in a battle behind the net gets taken down by
eel little pass here Raymond circles up high
he finds cider it goes off to Brink it down
low Raymond oh what a shotas Raymond has done
it again but time for Raymond to assess the
situation conect to cier back up the wall for
caler caler for Walker Walker quick shot he's
SC I don't know if it deflected but it found its
way in and there's your response the flyes back
on top 32 two came very easy the third one kept
me awake at night protus on the go fires off the
crossbar and down the red light is on I hit
the middle bar and out in a hurry there it is
marchenko he recovers nonetheless marchenko
it's an atly two career games against the
Hawks and a pair of goals and it's two nothing
as marchenko feeds G Branson off the post and
in once to again it across and here's G Branson
he's got a goal already this season exactly in
the Friday after Thanksgiving and this place is
jumping here tonight look out backand chance oh
between the skates score to the NHL on my list
he's one of four that made the jump from this
last year's draft kov picks it up again up top
to headman near side for kachra stles for a shot
scars power play goal from the captain he's got
a hot turns Keller goes to get it four goals here
tonight and we haven't even talked about schz and
Keller and a goal schz through a green posted in
what a wild one goals from Kane at newon Hopkins
for the white jersey Oilers back in the first
Bard who's the power play quarterback leans into a
blast he scores The Scouting Report says he has a
rocket uh-huh well you mentioned that in the first
period and toughy beginning the breakout they
fire him up ahead leaving it there and it's shot
they score it's Ross Colton and Colorado strikes
first Cami plays It Around the Net Oak with
swats and Terra Ving now sets up Cami he
scores in the slot NES verin made a great
save and nobody's stopping that from Cami
gets really low pink Jackson lome holds it in
nurse up the right hand side all of a sudden
three on one McDavid walks it shoots and scores
they trying to force and buries it has a lot of
time to walk in I mean look at this no no no
never really looked until he was going to go
far as side and put that puck in the net Point
you're getting to must score territory this is
a big moment for the Jets they control it and
it's Peretti with the drive he scor down low
and then Peretti right on the off the inside
of the post makes a perfect shot and juice